hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play grudge forest
okay this is another suggestion from you
guys and I need you guys to help me out
um if you have a suggestion for a game
that you want me to play but check to
see what games I have played already
send me an email
I'm always looking for new games to play
and interesting stuff like this I never
would have found this because it was on
some obscure website called yo-yo games
that I've never bought probably probably
not that obscure I'm just that ignorant
but anyway let's get into it
from the description it said it was a
mixture of The Grudge and slender seems
to be a pretty potent combination let's
see if it follows through yeah there we
go grudge slender right there you didn't
need me telling you about it that sounds
familiar
created by coq host night
I should probably develop my own
language with how I mispronounce names
Kakos cuckoos packhorses night grudge
forest with a little eye dangling right
there alright let's see what you got a
grudge forest I was on that terrified by
the grudge game that I played but then
again I didn't play the you the official
grudge game oh hello collect all eight
pages of the diary at least it gives me
oh wait oh oh okay it's not mouth space
that's why the lid no screw you help me
okay I can sprint a little bit but not
very far okay it's very mouse based arm
no go away
no thank you I don't want to help you I
am in it for myself I'm a greedy bastard
I'll help anybody but me okay so so far
yeah it's not exactly high-res but I
never count that against games if any of
you remember like the very
was that a cat siren-like from The
Nightmare Before Christmas you know the
cat siren that they were winding up the
Dale said that sounded like okay you
need to shut up because I'm novice we
not gonna help you haven't found
anything yet but I guess they're just
these small pathways the game window oh
hello
haha that's a big page this must be some
diary shut up no need to give me with
cheap jumps come on bring it on
grudge and brendor okay that's the
grudge sound
okay you need to stop that what is this
what is this oh this is oh no no I
thought this was like the concrete the
wooden square no thank you
those actually worried that something
might pop up when I turned around there
but now okay I'm looking for it well
what is this a bunch of go hello hey
that's two pages in a giant splash of
blood you know I've always thought that
the Slender games needed a lot more
blood not very gory to say the least
yeah I've actually thought about that
recently I just realized a lot of the
horror games I play don't have an
abundance of blood I mean usually that's
a go-to thing for like horror games but
apparently not hmm
anyway just me thinking out loud I've
got two pages and I've gotta know I shut
up cat stupid cat
get out here what are you yelling about
anyway we all got problems ah here we go
number three of this big ass diary
oh the sound is starting to pick up
sound chases after one three five and
seven pages
anything gonna happen nothing yet
I'm actually surprised that nothing's
happened in the past shut up cat Chhaya
- shut up trying to play a game here
trying to beats Lundy's grudge French
India stove sludge Slugger it it's oh
man it's sovereigns half-brother
sluggard anybody anyway like anybody
how's my favorite part of whatever I'm
talking can I actually go through here
no I cannot okay I thought I couldn't I
actually never tried though there's
literally no way that I would ever be
able to remember where I've been because
everything here looks exactly the same
which poses a problem in that this is
kind of a puzzle and I'm just kind of
scanning back and forth because the game
window is rather small so I don't have a
lot of room so I'm just I'm on the
lookout for for Slugger ah splutter
sluggers gonna get me
oh no not Slugger wow what am I gonna do
it's so thick should have called this
game what about a more creative title
than grudge for so here we go um Rick a
brick building surface thingy I can tell
that an extreme amount of work went into
this still haven't seen a single bit of
an enemy here
see wonder what game engine this is made
of cuz I have no idea oh I'm actually in
a like building with walls and no
ceiling I'll come on dead end
well here's hoping that when I turn
around there's gonna be something there
slugger
come here sludgy what you gonna do
sludgy sludgy bear
huh you won't give me a hug huh sludgy
doesn't want to come out to play sludgy
Slugger son aha lucky I found your diary
dear diary
markiplier looks for me today but I was
too shy
I couldn't bear possibly seeing his
incredible magnificence that's what he
said oh wait no that's back the way I
gotta get out of here ya know I might
almost get haunted by a screaming cat Oh
Oh No
I'm so scared Oh ppm invaders oh ok all
right let's take this more seriously
close it Oh so terrifying like a lot of
people like no realize but uh uh like
it's only certain things that get me
actual scared like if this this this is
this is an example of something that
doesn't scare me I'm not just jumping at
everything cuz obviously there's nothing
going on here like maybe if actually
slender decided to show his face I might
be a little concerned but nope nothing
so far
I mean slugger oh come on I can't make
it
ah get away from me I got stopped for a
day there son of a [ __ ] you get away
with that actually something
hmm
hmm okay so now I'm just walking around
the perimeter to the building and I
probably just got myself stuck I did I
went the wrong way
well I guess I means that sludgy can't
follow me oh no oh no oh no no no oh yo
see if I can get through here without
getting caught again Jesus shut up lady
or girl no girl what are you doing in
the woods guy not necessary
I really am wishing that something would
happen I probably should have put him
help me it's been a while since you said
that there was a period there were just
like complete silence
oh no what's going on I don't even know
where I am I don't know where I'm
supposed to go shoutout
I actually don't like that sound but
everything else is just fine that's like
the only thing in this game that's even
a little bit creepy cuz actually feels
like it's right behind me when that
sound goes off by just guess that's the
way it's designed okay come on
sluggard Slugger sluggard
what there isn't even a whoa okay whoa
no I'm not gonna retry Oh boring as hell
all right well I'm an Andy about a
minute there I'm gonna end it there um
because well basically that wasn't a
whole lot going on there there really
was not I mean I've got just pointing I
was like there's a lot of potentials if
you combine grudge and slender correctly
maybe do it in a better engine than
whatever the hell that was
I was reminiscent of like doom back in
my keyboard days control the fire space
to interact and that was way long ago
shift to strife you know all sorts of
stuff back then was good for that time
but that wasn't exactly area immersive
one because the window is like tiny one
because I couldn't look around I didn't
feel like I was actually the person and
two no one ever showed up okay so I have
a lot of criticisms about that game it's
not exactly the scariest game ever it's
not even that scary at all so if you
want to plot try it and try to get to
the end of game maybe you guys can
actually find some semblance of sluggard
and get him out there so yeah that's it
so thank you everybody so much for
watching link will be in the description
below and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
Oh
ma shorter
ah
bud
are you